ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina ha buttata oggi faremo
se come una delle merende più buona del
mondo più facili più veloci quella
dimentico di fare due mesi prima gli
interventi e benefico quindi solitamente
quando mi serve tirò fuori la ricotta
perché ho il latte di ottimo per fare la
pizza fritta napoletana al pessimo per
fare le crepe
ho deciso per questo video di seguire la
ricetta di chef stefano barbato ma
aggiungerci diciamo un tocco mio perché
perché non sono uno chef e soprattutto o
no si chef
io vorrei provare a vedere se si possono
fare l'interno della macchina più bella
che si è mai stata creata dall'uomo e
sto parlando del microonde
non lo so perché mi sento che
non è cioè verrà tutto bene e poi il
microonde cela piazzerà come sempre
super la crepa una bella nutellata per
fare queste crepe che di base potrete
utilizzare sia per fare roba dolce o
roba salata avrete bisogno di due uova
farina sale burro latte che non si è
scaduto multe la io riesco a sentirne
l'odore attraverso questa roba unità
antica non abbiamo una prolunga primo
ingrediente qui scusate ci metto questo
sopra che almeno blocchiamo i germi
prima però di metterci al lavoro è
essenziale indossare gli abiti del
mestiere
ok dopo aver preso il primo ingrediente
fondamentale che sono i bacilli di
enrico mettete subito due uova sono
stanco di fingere di non essere
all'altezza
prendiamo il sale aggiungete mamma mia
quanto sane ceco eventi un pizzico di
sale
sciacca la cala prende solo 100 g di
farina ma ne mettiamo 50 50 50 e 50
oddio sento la farina è fatta per
sporcare sempre questo momento catartico
il momento di g
poteva andare peggio iniziamo
prima seconda terza quarta quinta sesta
appena arriva la sesta ai meno miscelato
tutto quanto ho costruito niente mentre
tenete fra i vostri semi altre 50 stiamo
iniziando già sporcare troppo a roma per
delle crepe posso dirlo c'è da dire che
va bene tra una squadra sbagliata come
si chiama questo non lo usate perché
perché i grandi e mettono i loro errori
tutta quella farina ha creato sto mappa
azione infinito una spatola laica cioè
belle che ci fa quello con una spatola
effettivamente usa va a casa felice
no perché si incastra in mezzo agli
occhi
userò questa se fate così non dovrebbero
venir di grumi in cui facciamo
controllare i mille litri ecco come
dovresti fare la differenza tra fare poi
spiega non ho tempo per gli studi di
arrivare a 400 per aggiungerci 250
millilitri di latte secondo me un'ottima
teoria martelli anzi mamma quando mai
abbiamo fatto nelle qualche magenta
tornano fattosi e ad e adesso forse
emoziona molto liquido e latte
dove far diventare ma giusto ragazzi
giusto un tocchettino è scusa richard
stefano tra parentesi la mia ricetta
richiede una densità maggiore una noce
di burro che noi metteremo adesso
velocemente al microonde chi se lo
sarebbe mai aspettato
mi ricordo ma questo li fung osare
qualche novità
aggiungo il burro che si sarà sciolto in
realtà c'era non temete se il piatto
rimane sporco di burro anzi fate così
invece di mettervi subito a cucinare
lasciate le lasciate riposare per 20
minuti
non so perché l'ha detto lo chef quindi
molto probabilmente sarà perché devono
rilasciare il glutine sa cosa fare
quello che fa male
sono passati venti minuti andiamo a
tirar fuori la nostra crepe dal frigo
ragazzi scusate
l'idea a questo punto di fare questo
tentativo cosa abbiamo da perdere
non abbiamo credibilità ha mai avuto a
quanto si potrebbe tenere al microonde
non la mette al microonde uno chef mi
prendo tutte le responsabilità di questa
trovata pentola dentro l'amica nemica
giurata nel microonde
a girarla quindi fornetto alimentare che
siano grazie
che scoperta di farla da un lato e da un
altro non credo proprio
non credo che funzioni così la tonico
ronde spiega non è quella tonico le due
ci facciamo spesso si vede meglio così
che ha un film
guarda il tuo riflesso che le si vede
dovrò fare delle cose contestano facendo
delle bolle diventano tutt'uno sembra
cotta e crepe nel senso che crepi
se le cose si provi a mangiarla se
qualcuno di voi ha mai provato a farle
al microonde mi faccia sapere qua sotto
qual è la tecnica ma ho capito che
questa tecnica non funziona quindi per
la prima volta all'interno di questo
canale proveremo a utilizzare il fuoco
io proporre a farla girare verso è mica
sono nato ieri
spostiamoci nella mia altra cucina già
un altra cosa dalla mamma mia posso dire
ragazzi liscia la devi cuocere parecchio
diciamo sotto per fare la giravolta
non so se alla scuola di microonde
terrorismo alla scuola innalza me
l'hanno insegnato se pronto
ecco qua ci sarà fiero di te
il prete di continuate voi ne faccio
altre
fatto la frittata st botta ragazzi ve lo
dico io direi di fissare in tanto che si
cucina ammettere la nutella
intanto che è ancora calda e non sono
mai stato bravo per cucinare non
sopportarti lidi e ragazzi non mi lasci
spalmarlo scusa cosi paolo rodella
mangio io questa questa non mi sembra
pazzesco
l'aquila la maglia giornata del mario
germania questa è la mia si sanno bene
cos'è questo non è più la mia io voterà
così ti va bene ti spalmo bene questa va
benissimo anche quel porko di materico
convinti che il baratto
ma non capisco come faccio questa è
mamma mia ragazzi grazie guglielmo
allora enrico la differenza tra me e te
tumori
anzi è un fagottino è qui nessun altra
mi sa che li faccia sentire quando
dovrebbe sbrigarsi
altrimenti adesso
e arrivato il momento o di fallire
miseramente o di fare imperfecta malone
si mettono in teoria più strati di
nutella centrale gengive cucchiaio di
nutella morse cucchiaio di nutella
questo è un sorriso mi sembra modo
bellissimo
mamma mia ma posso trovare io vai diceva
no no no niente
era bella questa
perché io ci sta è city
credo sia arrivato il momento di
assaggiare queste crepe e per la prima
volta in questa cucina
preparate i vostri palati enrico jami
proviamo fatemi sapere
una bella dentro
so boni tutti per operare una volta è un
piacere
l'insufficiente
questo è un porco parte con un boccone
paradiso recchi e spazi lasciamole ai
commensali lasciamole a chi deve veni no
no io basta altro afflitto è tutto
capire che nel libro di chef stefano si
sfiora in questo impasto non ho capito
se va mai siete voi se va bene share
stefano io non ho fatto niente ma se
invece ci facessimo sparire di nascosto
quelle crepe non devono stare tutti che
abbiamo fatto tanto lo sapranno
preoccuparvi i prezzi finite cola erano
pronti per vivere in realtà non me la
mangio una metà a un terzo
e dico tu prendi la tutta quale volete
prendo questa caccia medi minuto prendi
questa e pisciotta mamma mia come vaio
certo ammette lontana pure qua te li
morto finalmente una ricetta non fa bene
emorroidi e palladino abbagliato nessuno
oggi le garanzie tornerò coincidenze non
credo ragazzi prima della fine di questa
ricetta
questo è il piatto finisco io
personalmente un problema perché
all'interno delle crepe metto solamente
la nutella ma fatemi sapere qua sotto
magari se avete delle alternative dolci
e salate le quali io non ho mai
minimamente pensato né mai prese in
considerazione mi sa che porta ci metto
pure il mascarpone poi sono io volo lì
che c'è il vale dentro la creato ci sono
come silenziati perché dire grazie per i
vostri consigli
fatemi sapere che tipo di ricerche mi
piacerebbe vedere all'interno di questo
canale
ma soprattutto questo però non può ma
soprattutto ci vediamo la frase domenica
con un altro video
ciao